John McCain this year says he's running
on the transcendent issue of combating
radical Islamic terrorism worldwide in
2000 he was also running on a
transcendent issue his term not mine
about getting big money out of politics
back then one of the reasons why
everyone referred to him as a maverick
is that he was going against his own
political party and trying to push
through campaign finance reform or to
put it more accurately the regulation of
political speech people who want to
start a group you know maybe get a
couple of friends together and petition
the government run an advertisement
develop politician whose policies they
disagree with now because of mccain
feingold have to enter into an elaborate
database and follow all kinds of very
restrictive rules about how they can
raise money this is a in my view a
complete abridgement to the freedom of
speech especially its original intent of
protecting political speech well in 2008
somehow this transcendent issue has
largely gone away you can follow McCain
around for days and he won't even bring
it up which goes to show you if nothing
else that here's a man who needs
transcendence more than he needs a
consistent issue necessarily in st. Paul
this week it's a strong issue it's one
of the reasons why mccain has always had
a testy relationship with his base is
because either a lot of people feel for
very principled reason that this is an
abridgment in the First Amendment or
maybe they were a group that has been
trying to raise money and his bill
prevented them from doing it at any rate
the three words you will not hear all
week long probably in st. Paul our
campaign finance reform
you